So on Thursday we will do the final
examination. This is an opportunity for
you to question and challenge my
understanding of the world. Um and so
today what I'm going to do is review all
that we've learned this semester and
combine together into a framework of how
the world works. Okay. So the main
driving question of the semester is
why
did the US
attack
Iran? Right? So this is the central
mystery
of the world today because even today
Donald Trump has yet to articulate a
reason for attacking Iran. And I I do
understand that right now there are
ceasefire negotiations going on. But
unless we can properly understand or
diagnose the rationale for this war,
it's very hard for us to appreciate the
difficulty of coming to a ceasefire.
Okay. So I'm going to present to you the
three major reasons that we learn in
this class as to why the United States
attacked Iran. Okay. The first major
explanation is this geopolitical
geopolitics.
And so um according to this theory, what
the United States is most afraid of is
that
Russia, Iran, and China would come
together into a grand alliance. Okay? So
you have Russia here, [snorts]
you have China here, and you have Iran
here.
Okay. Now, why the United States is
afraid of this grand alliance is that if
these three nations were to combine
together and just trade amongst
themselves,
they could encompass the entire Eurasian
continent, which would include Europe,
um the entire of the Middle East, the
GCC, uh Africa,
India,
and they could negate
the American maritime power and just
trade amongst themselves using railways
constructed by China. All right. And
there's nothing America could do about
it. And that's a huge problem because
right now the Americans have $39
trillion
in debt.
And so the only way to finance this debt
is to force others to continue to buy US
treasuries. Okay. So the reason why the
United States attacked Iran is to force
everyone to buy US treasuries. Why?
Well, because if you attack Iran, you
knock off at least 20% of the world's
energy.
And as a result, the world, Europe,
uh, China
and Japan specifically are forced to buy
more US treasuries.
And then by knocking out Iran, you can
start to control the world's major choke
points instead of the straight of
Hmoose, the straight of Jialter,
uh, sorry, the straight of Malaka.
Actually, this is the straight of
Jialter. This is the cape of gold um uh
good hope. Um and so as a result you
control the world's trade. So if you any
if the world wants resources they can
only do so from buying from the western
hemisphere that America controls. Okay.
So attacking Iran is crucial to
achieving
um the geopolitical vision of America uh
in order to maintain the American
empire. Okay. So that's the first major
reason. Okay. There's also another
explanation which is different very
different and this is esquetological.
Number two is esqueological.
And what this means is that there are
religious fanatics within the American
Empire who believe that a war in the
Middle East will launch a chain of
events that will ultimately culminate in
the return of Jesus. Okay. So these are
people who believe very strongly in the
Bible and they believe that what the
Bible teaches them is that if there is a
war in the Middle East, okay, this Iran
war,
this will lead to
um the third temple
which would in which would also uh
involve the destruction of the alaxic
mosque, the third holiest site in the
Islamic world uh which would lead to the
war of Gog and Magog.
um which would lead to the rise of the
antichrist.
Now, at this point, if you are Jewish,
you believe that this will lead to the
coming of the Messiah and the ushering
in of the messianic age. If you're a
Christian, you believe that this will
lead to the second coming of Jesus and
the rapture, sorry, the rapture and the
uh millennium of peace in the world
before the day of judgment and then
heaven comes to earth. Okay. Now what's
interesting about this esquetological
vision is that it also aligns with both
the Islamic esquetology
as well as the orthodox esquetology.
Okay, this is important because the
Islamic of course is Iran and the
orthodox is Russian.
And so what's really strange is that the
four major nations involved right now in
this war in the Middle East including
Iran, Russia, uh the United States and
Israel
share similar esqueological outlook
and as a result they're all actually in
many ways working together to achieve a
certain geopolitical outcome which
includes the building of the third
temple, the war of God, talking Magog uh
the coming of the antichrist
and ultimately uh the end of the world.
Okay, so that's the second explanation
for what's happening.
The third reason is actually the most
mundane. Okay, and the third reason is
this imperial decline.
And when an empire declines, it does all
sorts of stupid things. Because
internally it is fracturing for three
reasons. The first reason is
financialization,
which is to say that you have a few
people who control all the capital and
as a result all they do is force
everyone into debt slavery. uh and then
everyone's forced to engage in
speculation in order to try to get rich
because there's no honest way to make a
living. All right, so capital controls
the empire and this is this leads to
corruption, inequality and debt and
ultimately slavery. Um, second problem
is demographic crisis. And this is true
for all empires in decline in that young
people refuse to have children. But not
only that, but old people live longer
and longer. So you have this huge
problem where old people live longer and
longer. They have pensions. They require
young people to work, but young people
don't want to have babies. Okay? So just
naturally over time the empire is going
to collapse. So the way for the empire
to resolve this issue is for
immigration. So they welcome millions
and millions of outsiders in order to do
the jobs no one actually wants to do and
this leads to ethnic tension within the
empire. Okay. The third reason uh the
third symptom of impro decline is
something called elite overp production
which is a phrase coined by a historian
named Peter Turchin
and he argues that if you look at all
societies in decline it's driven by the
fact that you have certain elites who
want to control policy who want power
but power by it by definition is a zero-
sum And so these elites compete for the
limited positions of power and this
leads to civil war. And one
manifestation of the civil war is that
this war is projected outwards. Okay,
that's why an empire does stupid things
like go invade Venezuela for no reason,
goes attacks Iran for no reason. Right
now America is talking about take over
Greenland, Canada, Mexico, Colombia,
Cuba. Okay. So, um this is the other
explanation for why things are happening
the way they are because empire is
declined. All these internal conflicts
that are destroying the empire from
within are projected outwards. And so
this um turmoil is projected onto Iran.
Okay. So these are the three major
reasons. Now what's interesting about
these three major reasons is that
they're actually not in competition with
each other. In fact, they support each
other and honestly they lead to the same
outcomes. If you believe in the
esquetological model, okay, you believe
that this is the end of days. You
believe that the Israelis will build a
third temple. You believe that this war
in the Middle East will just expand
outwards before it encompasses the
entire world. Something called the war
of Gog and Magog. You believe that a
charismatic leader will rise to uh unify
much of the world. Um and if you just
analyze the geopolitical framework, you
can actually come to the same
conclusions. If you look at the imperial
decline framework, you can also come to
the same conclusions. Okay, this is
really really strange in that you have
these three divergent explanations for
what's going on, but in many ways
they're very very similar. In fact, they
lead to the same conclusions. So what I
I want to discuss today is why is this
the case? Why is it that esquetology and
geopolitics and empirical decline all
end up giving the same understanding of
the world and forces us to make certain
predictions about the world. Okay. So
um
my explanation to you is this.
Essentology
is really just an understanding of
geopolitics
framed allegorically.
Okay. So we're saying this is that what
esquetology really is, it's not
religion. What it is is it takes
thousands of years of human history,
tens of thousands of years of human
history and condenses it into stories
that then can be told to children and
passed on through generations and
generations. Okay? So it is impossible
for humans to pass on complex history
over thousands of years. But it is easy
to take these this history, frame it
into stories and then tell it to your
children, remember it and then these
these children will then pass it on to
their children and then this is how we
develop esquetology.
Okay.
So then the question then is why how did
we develop this particular framework of
esquetology where uh a war in the Middle
East will lead to the third temple, the
return of the Jews to Israel, the war of
Gog and the coming of the antichrist
before the coming of the Messiah. Where
does the story come from? And what I
will show you now is that this is
actually a persistent story in the
Middle East. The first thing that I need
you guys to appreciate is the Middle
East, especially the Levant, is the most
important part of the world. Why?
Because historically, it's been the
wealthiest part of the world. All right,
so let's look at the Levant. This is the
Levant,
okay? Which includes present day Israel,
Syria, Jordan, Lebanon. What's below the
Levant? Egypt.
What's above the leavant? Anatolia.
Then if you go further uh east, what do
you get? You get Mesopotamia.
Okay.
If you keep on going east, what do you
get? You get Persia.
Okay. And then you keep on going east,
you get India.
Okay. And historically
this part of the world was the center of
the universe. The wealthiest, the most
advanced, the most geopolitically
important. And the hinge, the pivot is
the Levant.
Okay.
Now, historically, Egypt and Mesopotamia
were the wealthiest parts of the world.
Uh, by the way, Mesopotamia includes um
Babylon
and Assyria. Okay.
All right. So, everyone wants to conquer
Egypt, but the way to conquer Egypt is
through the Levant. So, recon Levant has
a huge advantage over everyone else.
Okay. Now, because of historical
accident called the Bronage collapse,
the Israelites came into being. Okay.
Israel
and Israel is a crossroads of empire.
And again this was this was historical
accident. You had the branch age
collapsed. So Anatolia, Mesopotamia and
Egypt declined in power which allowed
for a new power to rise in the Lemon
called Israel. But they they only stayed
in power for about 1500 years. After
that they become became a subject to an
empire which is a historical norm.
But because they were so important
um it was easy for Israel to keep on
switching sides. Maybe today they
supported Israel, the next day they
supported Mesopotamia, then they
supported Anatolia. Okay? But whoever
paid them the most, whoever brought them
the most, they would support. And so
this area became the most contested
territory in the world, which led to all
sorts of apocalyptic wars. Okay? Lots
and lots of death.
um and the Israelites suffer the most
because obviously their location
um led to a lot of conflict. Now the the
Israelites create something called the
Bible
and this would change human history
forever because what the Bible is it's a
collective memory
and the Israelites were called people of
the book. Okay. So to be an Israelite
meant that you believe the Bible and
what's the Bible? The Bible is
collective stories that became your
collective memory. So it's entirely
possible with the Bible now for people
to have never been to Israel to not be
Israelite in blood, but to read the
Bible and then imagine themselves as an
Israelite.
Okay? And this is unique in human
history. And if you're an Israelite,
what do you want to do? You want to
return to Jerusalem because Jerusalem is
where God lives. Okay? If you want to
fulfill your destiny, you must return to
Jerusalem. So what's happening in this
time is that um the Levant is contested
territory. The Israelites are a pain in
the ass to deal with and different
empires try different solutions.
uh you could try to bribe them and then
ultimately the solution they came up
with is you know what let's just remove
them from uh Israel so they went to
Babylon something called the Babylon
exile okay
um but remember they have the Bible with
them so even though they are now removed
from Israel the land itself and the
people the the priests still have this
historical memory of Israel so they long
to return to it.
Then what happened was that Persia under
Sith the great comes and conquers
Babylon and he meets these Jewish
priests who long to return to Israel.
And then what the person figure out is,
hey, if we insert the Jews back into
Israel and now they are strangers in a
strange land,
they must be loyal to us only because
only we can protect them because only we
can protect identity. Okay. So the
Persians would sponsor the return of the
Israelites to
um Israel and now they're called the
Jews.
Okay? And now what's happened is not
only the Jews long to return to
Israel, but they also recognize that
only by working with an empire against
other empires can we return to Israel.
Okay? And this pattern will repeat
itself throughout human history. Okay?
So after the Persians, the Romans come
and again the Romans need to control
this territory because of Egypt. The
Jews rebel against the Romans because
the Romans insist that the Jews were
obey Roman law, obey the emperor. The
emperor is the lie. But that that that
goes against Jewish belief. Okay. This
leads to a civil series of wars. Uh Rome
kills the Jews. The Jews are forced into
Arabia, the Arabian desert. And there
they take their Bible and they start
teaching the locals
about their religion. And this will give
rise to a new religion called Islam.
Back here in the Levant, a new religion
is rising
um in order to try to control the Jews.
And this new religion is called
Christianity.
And of course Christianity will also
give rise to orthodox
orthodoxy which is the religion of the
Russians. Okay. So the esquetology is so
in so similar because all the major
religions come from this conflict in the
lavant and the pattern that emerges is
the Jews are central to this story
because the Jews are trying to return to
Jerusalem
build the temple which is where the god
lives and but to do so they must fight
empires that are trying to use them as
pawns
also.
For the Jews to thrive, they need a
leader. Okay? This leader is called the
Messiah.
And it was
prophesized in the Bible that God would
send the Messiah, the son of man, to
lead them to ultimate victory.
But
historically, whenever the Jews try to
revolt, they lose.
So now the problem is you have this
great story, you have this great belief
that's kind of repeats itself over time.
But how do you explain the failure of
the Messiah? The answer of course is the
antichrist.
What is the antichrist? The antichrist
is the false prophet, the false messiah.
So this is a story that doesn't really
work. And so they add the story in a
certain way to make it believable. Okay.
So, we're going to say, you know what,
the Messiah came and we lost. So, this
means the story is nonsense. No, no, no.
That was not the real Messiah. That was
a lesser messiah or the antichrist.
Okay, we need lesser messiahs or the
antichrist to come before the Messiah
himself can come. Okay, this is how we
got the story. What's amazing about this
is that this story would be applied
throughout uh the the history of this
area. So after the Roman Jewish wars,
the next thing we have about 600 uh CE
is the rise of Islam and the rise of
Muhammad.
And if you look into the history of the
rise of Islam and the Muhammad, a very
similar framework where there's two
empires fighting each other uh the
Romans and the Persians and um a Messiah
merges Muhammad to unite the world, the
Muslims, the Jews and the Christians and
they very quickly return to Jerusalem
and build the temple to uh God, the
third temple which which is now called
the Alex mosque. Okay. All right. So in
other words,
the history of the Middle East has been
condensed into a simple escalatoral
story that gives us insight into how
geopolitics works in the Middle East.
For the longest time, the Middle East,
especially Levant, was a crossroads of
empire. So there's always going to be
war fought over that territory. The Jews
long to return to Jerusalem. So, they're
going to figure out ways in order to
return to uh Jerusalem. And that often
means working with different empires.
Okay? And during this war, you're going
to have meic fever. You're going to have
people who believe that I am Messiah.
They're going to come and lead the
Jewish people. And because the Jewish
people are looking for Messiah, well,
then he becomes a Messiah because he
volunteers to be the Messiah. Okay? When
he fails, he's like, "No, he's actually
the le Messiah or he's the Antichrist."
Okay?
And this is a pattern that that is
consistent in the Middle East. And
therefore, we can assume that this is a
pattern that will continue. Okay? Okay.
So we can expect the next few years the
same thing will happen where maybe in
the Middle East a man will emerge to and
he declares himself the Messiah because
everyone is expecting the Messiah to
emerge and if he fails then he's just
the antichrist or he's a lesser messiah.
Okay, does that make sense? Okay. And a
lot of this is being driven by the idea
of imperial decline.
Okay. Meaning that this is possible
because the empire is too weak to stop
this messianic
um uh vision from emerging in the
Levant.
Okay. And the empires which which before
included Rome and Persia, they would
externalize their internal conflict. So
we can see from this how all this
combines together. Okay. Estology is
just
geopolitics told in a story
and the main driver of geopolitical of
geopolitics esquetology is imperial
decline.
All right? Because it loses equilibrium.
It loses stability and so all these
events converge together in one
particular pace. Okay? Does that make
sense guys? Okay. Now I want to discuss
another question which is
why is esquetology so powerful.
Okay. How is it possible for esquetology
to drive geopolitics?
And the answer has to do with the
structure of power in society. Okay. So
let me explain what's going on.
Okay. So the first thing you guys need
to appreciate
is that
the occult
is the basis of everything.
Okay. The occult is basis of reality.
The occult means u basically esoteric or
hidden knowledge
or a mystical understanding of how the
universe works.
Okay. Another saying this is
action comes after ideas. Only if we can
imagine the action can the action
actually take place. Okay. And the
occult all these mystics who are trying
to figure out the secrets of the
universe which includes alchemy,
esquetology,
uh astronomy, astrology. Okay. Okay.
Alchemy is just trying to transmute or
transform nothing into something. Okay,
basically lead into gold or uh death
into life. Okay, you're trying to
animate uh things. Eiology is an
understanding of how the world ends.
Astrology is an understanding of how the
moving the stars influences
historical patterns. Okay. All right.
Right? So these are the three main
fields. Now
um there are people in power okay who
form secret societies
and there are lots and lots of them okay
and they form secret societies because
they want to access the secrets of the
occult in order to gain more power and
wealth for themselves.
Because if you think about it
um
the if you the more secrets you have the
more power you have. Okay. So that
that's why they form secret societies in
order to worship the occult in order to
obtain more power for themselves. Once
these secret societies and these occult
and the cult form an alliance they
transform each other. Okay. The cult
before was very much just focused on
esoteric knowledge. But once it comes in
contact with these secret societies,
then they focus more about esquetology.
Okay? Because now they have the
mechanism, the means in order to achieve
their esquetology and the end of the
world. The elite like esquetology
because they believe that if they're
able to bring up about the end of the
world, then they themselves can have the
most power because they'll be close to
God. Also, what's important for you guys
to understand is secret societies do not
believe they can change the world. They
cannot they don't believe they can
actually alter the course of history.
What they believe is they can ride the
wave of history into absolute power.
Okay? And then once this alliance is
formed, what they do now is they
basically select leaders or agents or
puppets or scape, okay? whatever name
you want to call them and become the
person who propel who propels history
forward. Okay, these are the agents and
historically these people included
Napoleon or
uh Julius Caesar or Hitler or Stalin.
Today they are of course Trump and Putin
because you need an individual
to capture imagination of the people and
create action in order to achieve this
esquetology. Okay, does that make sense?
So this is a basic framework of how
history happens. Okay, you always need
the occult in order for history to if
you don't have the occult, you end up
like China. Okay. Trying to just focus
on harmony and balance.
All right.
Um once you have their code, then that
gives you the secret societies who then
pick agents in order to achieve the
astrological vision. Okay. Now I want to
discuss why these secret societies are
so powerful and it has to do with
the structure of society. Okay. So
society is often bureaucratized into
different departments. You have the
military,
you have the political system,
you have um science or religion,
you have finance,
you have the bureaucracy.
Okay? So just basically different
segments of society. Now, within each
segment, you're going to have a range of
personality types. Most people just want
to live normal lives. They want to get
along. They want to collect their
paycheck, go home, and raise their
families. That's all they care about.
About 90% of people are like that. Okay?
Then you have some extreme people who
are more idealistic. Then you have more
extreme people who are power hungry.
Okay? And these pe people that are power
hungry, they converge together and they
work together because they're all more
interested in order and control.
All right? In order to obtain more order
and control, they form secret societies.
And um once they have these secret
societies, they're able to achieve three
things that give them more power and
control over other people. Okay. The
first is secrecy.
Second is uh trust.
The last is coordination.
Okay. And how they're able to achieve
this is through esquetology.
Escotology
is a script for them to act out. Okay?
And that allows for them to coordinate
even though they may not know actually
what they're doing. Okay? Because
they're all trying to achieve the same
script.
Okay. Does that make sense so far? Okay.
Are there any questions before I
continue?
Any questions? Okay. All right.
So now what I I want to discuss is this.
Why is estology so powerful?
Why why does it compel us to do things
that are from an outsiders perspective
irrational or extreme or fanatical like
start wars in the Middle East? And the
argument I want to make to you to you is
that the reason why is that esquetology
that we have today in the Middle East,
it is fundamentally sexual in nature.
sexual in nature.
All right? So remember this that the
esquetology it's not just an idea. It's
sexual. It's something that you want to
move towards. You're driven by this
sexual urge in order to fulfill the
esquetology. Okay? All right. So let me
explain how this works. All right. So we
first start off with the occult, right?
and I'm going to show you how it leads
to esquetology.
Okay. Um,
so the most dominant understanding of
the cult is something called
hermeticism,
hermetic philosophy. It comes to us from
Egypt.
Okay.
And there are seven basic principles of
hermetic philosophy.
Okay. The first is that everything is
mind. Everything is energy. Everything
is vibration. So you start off with a
source. We'll call it the monad or the
source.
And what the source does is it breathes.
It emanates. It thinks it meditates. And
so it [snorts] vibrates. Okay. [gasps]
Om.
Okay. And it's infinite. Okay. So it's
it is it has infinite vibrations.
Okay. And the higher the vibration is
the faster it is. Okay. The lower it is
the slower it is. And so this gives rise
to the material world.
So yes. So even though the dimensions
are infinite, we can roughly classify
them in different categories. Okay. At
the very bottom is the material world
which is our world. Then you might have
the emotional.
Then you might have the spiritual.
Then you might have the divine. Okay.
All right. Now
according to hermetic philosophy, there
are certain characteristics about this
universe. Okay. The first is that there
is rhythm to it.
Okay? Meaning there's a pattern to its
vibrations. It's not just random chaos.
There's a pattern to it. And this
pattern will become the basis for
astrology. Right? That's what astrology
is. Astrology is trying to figure out
the pattern of the stars. Okay? Which
determines the movement of the universe.
Second thing is the idea of
correspondence.
All right. What correspondence means is
that divine, spiritual, emotional,
material, they all line up. Okay? They
all correspond to each other. They're
not different realms. They're all realms
that can influence each other. This then
leads to idea of cause and effect,
which is that the entire universe is
combined together. So that what happens
in material world can impact the vine.
What happens in the vine can impact the
material. Okay. And what this means and
this is really interesting is that you
can have impact on others as well. So
this gives rise to the idea of
telepathy.
Okay. And there's a belief that if you
if you meditate long enough, okay, if
you will it long enough, you can make
something happen. There's something the
idea of manifestation. Okay. So there
are many secrets to this.
Okay, this gives idea this gives rise to
the idea of as below
so above and this has to do with the
idea of the interconnectedness of this
universe. What this means basically is
that the universe are just fractals of
each other. Okay, fractalss of each
other. So you in your mind you are just
a fractal of the entire universe and the
entire universe is a reflection of you
yourself. Okay, does that make sense? As
above, as above so below, as below, so
above. The interconnectedness of
everything. Okay. Um then this gives
rise to idea of polarity. Polarity just
means opposites. So if black, if there's
a black, there must be a white. If
there's a female, there must be a male.
Okay. So, the universe is divided into
extremes into opposites.
Then this gives to the um gives rise to
the idea of
um uh generation the generative
principle.
Okay. So, you have generate generation
and production.
So production is the female,
generation is the male. Okay, this is a
fundamental movement of the universe
where new things are created when the
male and the female come together. When
the ying and the yang come together. All
right, so think of um thesis,
antithesis,
synthesis.
And this is what allows for the universe
to constantly create new things. Okay.
So these are the seven fundamental
principles of the universe. First
everything is energy, everything is
mind. Everything is vibration. That's
number one. Number two is there's a
pattern to all this. Number three is the
different dimensions correspond with
each other. They're all connected
somehow. Number four is cause effect
where if you make one movement in the
spir in the in the material world, you
can also influence the vine. Okay? You
can also influence others as well. Uh as
above so below. So that we're all
reflections of God itself, the universe
itself. Polarity, there are opposite uh
and these opposites work together to
create the life force. Okay, that that
allows for creativity. Okay, so these
are seven basic principles of the uh
universe. Okay, and this has been known
for a long time ever since the Egyptians
then it went over to India. So now
what's going to happen is about um
to 1,200 okay around this time a new
force is something called luranic
capitalism
is going to come into being okay why
because hermetic philosophy is the most
intuitive understanding of the universe
the Bible are the most powerful stories
in the universe and so what uh Laria
Isaac Laria who is a Jew Jewish rabbi
what he's going to do is he's he's going
to combine the two together meaning he's
going to take the stories of the Bible
and explain it using hermetic philosophy
okay so let me give an example story of
Adam and Eve in the Bible great story
all right um God created Adam and then
from Adam created Eve and told the two
together and told the two This is the
Garden of Eden. This is paradise. You'll
never die. You always have enough to
eat. You guys can have sex every day.
But there's only one thing I ask you not
to do. And it's like, don't eat the
fruit from the tree of knowledge. And
that's it guys. That's all you have to
do. Don't do that. And then of course
they eat that stupid fruit and they get
banished from the garden of Eden. Okay.
So this is a story
of the Bible. And the question that's
plagued many religious scholars for
thousands of years is why did they screw
up? Okay. And now what they're going to
do is they're they're they're going to
take hermetic philosophy and explain the
story of Adam and Eve using hermetic
philosophy. Okay. And this this
explanation
the explanation is in the beginning God
was everything. Okay. God was
everything. God is eternal, immutable,
perfect,
but it wants to know itself. It's
curious. It wants to expand itself.
Okay? And God is the will to bestow.
The will to give, the giver. But if you
are the will to bestow, then you need
something to give it to. You need
something to give yourself to. Okay? So
what God does, he is he contracts. He
starts to build the universe. The first
being that he creates is called
something called Adam Kenmmont.
Okay? Which becomes the will to receive,
okay? Or the ego. Does that make sense,
guys? Okay. So, God in order to bestow
must create a new being called Adam
Kenmont in so so that he can bestow
himself onto
um an Kenmon. Okay.
The problem though is that Adam Connan
is the ego. So he can only see the world
through the lens of selfishness.
God is love. God is forgiveness. God is
generosity. So God wants to give. But
Adam's like why do you want to give to
me? All right. So, so, so the analogy is
let's just say I invite you to my house
and I am honored that you come to my
house and I cook you a wonderful meal.
Okay, 12 courses. It's sumptuous.
You come into my house and you are
shocked. You're embarrassed by my
generosity. You run away because you
figure think myself does he want to
borrow money from me? like like why is
he being so nice to me? Okay, it scares
you. And that's why Adam and Eve
disobeyed God because they were
embarrassed by the generosity of God.
They were too immature. They were too
egotistical, too selfish to appreciate
the generosity of God. Okay? And so when
this happens, when Adam and Eve betrayed
God, this is something called breaking
the world.
And the point of the universe is to
repair the world.
How do you repair the world?
By making yourself
so
um enlightened that you can now receive
the generosity of God and create a
reunion. Okay, that is the repair of the
world. A reunion. Now there are
different ways in which you can do this.
Okay. The the way they teach you is just
basically self-enlightenment
through education through knowledge.
Another way is love. Okay. Love thy
neighbor.
embark
on a journey, a lifelong journey to be
as nice and kind to people as possible.
Okay, the modern term for this is of
course called social justice.
All right,
try to save as many people as possible.
But there's a third way and this and the
third way is most controversial which is
the idea of sin.
Okay.
And the idea of sin is
you must break yourself
before you can
learn the wisdom to welcome God into
your heart. And the story that explains
this idea is sort of David. Okay. King
David
was the greatest ruler of the
Israelites.
And one day he falls in love with a
woman named Bashibba.
[snorts]
And David is king because he's close to
God. God favors him. Okay. He falls in
love with Bashibba. The problem, okay?
And so Bashibba and David have sex.
Bashibba becomes pregnant. The problem
is that Bashibba is married
to a warrior named Ure Urea the Heitite.
So David thinks of many ways of solving
this problem and and ultimately he
decides I'm just going to kill this guy.
Okay. So he kills Uria the Hitite and he
marries Bashibba and he's very happy and
he's going to and Bashib is going to
give birth to their son.
God learns about this and sends his
prophet Nathan to David and says, "King
David, do you know what you've done
wrong?" And David's like, "Not really. I
mean, what did I do wrong? I don't know.
So God gets angry and punishes David by
killing his son and this forces David
into mourning. And when he mourns, he
breaks his heart. When he breaks his
heart, he welcomes God back into his
soul. And the two become the best of
friends because every day now David is
praying to God and God is answering him.
David has given up all the material
desires of this world and fully embraced
God. He's he's humbled himself before
God. He's become God's servant. He's
everything he asked for forgiveness.
He's engaged in poetry, in prayer. Okay?
So, the Israelites remember David not as
a great conqueror, not as a great king,
but as a man who understood his
humility, who always asked for
forgiveness, who was best friends with
God. Okay? And this is the idea of
repairing the world.
Nothing matters except your relationship
with God. The world whole world could be
in nuclear war. Doesn't matter. Okay.
What matters is your true faith in God.
And so from these three things, we now
understand what's going on in Gaza and
the Middle East where the Israel is the
Israelis think that hey, if I break the
world and I force the entire world to
hate me and I sin so much that
I suffer, that's a good thing because
that's going to let me develop a close
relationship with God and this will
repair the world. But and this is really
important, okay? We also need need to
appreciate is that there are there are
also Jews in the and who are more
numerous than the the the Israelis who
think no that's wrong. What's important
is the idea of social justice. Okay, to
stand for what is right. That's why dur
during what was happening in Gaza, if
you go to American universities, the
protesters, most of them were actually
Jews protesting what's happening in
Israel. Okay, so this shows you the
diversity and debate within the Jewish
tradition, but it also tells us they're
actually looking for the same thing.
Okay, what they're looking for is
reunion with God. Now, why I bring this
up is that the idea of the Cabala
because it's able to take the stories of
the Bible and make it mystical and give
it a deeper meaning. The cabala has
become the most powerful mystical
tradition in the world. Becomes a basis
for most secret societies especially the
Freemasons. Okay, which control America.
Okay. And the thing about the Cabala
that we need to appreciate is that it's
different from other occult tradition in
that it's sexual in nature.
Okay. You are moving towards a
symphysis. You're moving towards a
reunion with God. And the sexual aspect
to the cabala is what it what energizes
galvanizes people into action. Okay. The
sexual nature comes from its um
physicality.
It's um corporality. Okay. Corporality.
The fact that you can feel it that feel
the fact that you can touch it. Most
mystical traditions are just monks
meditating. Okay. meditating and trying
to to uh achieve the divine. But the
cabala is about achieving the stories of
the Bible. Becoming David, okay?
Becoming Moses, becoming
um Isaac, Joseph.
All right? So, because of the Cabala,
the esquetology
becomes sexual in nature. Because it's
sexual in nature, it energizes us. Okay?
It becomes very urgent and immediate
and that's help that helps us explain
why things are happening so fast because
the people involved these societies
they're trying to climax as soon as
possible. Okay? They believe that the
faster I move the more I'll be able to
reunite with God. Okay? So they want to
accelerate. This is accelerationism.
Okay.
Accelerationism.
All right. Okay. Um, you have a
question. I think if the people in the
secret society see uh they need to see
the cabala as a sexual thing that that
the I think the um condition that they
must have a strong belief. But I think a
belief is rational. How can it be sexual
to them just like the sex of human that
it's sort of a sense of biological?
>> Okay. Um Okay. Um Okay. I hate to say
this, but you're you're way too young to
to understand what's going on. Okay.
It's hard for for me to to explain to
you using theory. You just have to know
this. Okay. Belief is not abstract.
Okay. Belief is your soul, your heart.
Belief is what your soul aspires to. And
for most of human history, most
religious traditions believe that the
soul was divine. Okay? It was not
material. It's removed from the
material. The cabala by almost an
accident. It makes the soul almost have
a sexual urge. Okay? So, it drives the
soul to action. Right? Again, you know,
I I can't explain to you this to you.
You either know this or you don't know
this. Okay? All right. Okay. So, um,
this is the esquetology. All right. So,
um, to further explain to you what's
going on, I'm going to use a metaphor,
okay? Called Plato's cave. We've said
this before,
okay? Plato's cave. So, what Plato's
cave is going to do is it's going to
take all this occult hermetic
understanding and transform into a story
that we can all understand. And once we
understand the story, it helps us better
understand the movement of history.
Okay? So Plato's cave. So imagine a
cave. There's a blank wall, all right,
in front of everyone. And everyone is
lined up together as prisoners. They are
chained to the floor. They're stuck
there. And there's about a million of
them, okay? And their necks are shackled
so they can't move. And look behind
them. Behind them is a great fire.
[snorts]
Um, and there are certain people, we
don't know who they are. It's just like
they, okay, Plato just uses the word
they to describe them. And what they do
is they take shadows and project the
shadows on to the wall. And the people,
the prisoners don't know any better. So
they think these shadows who are just
random shapes, it's reality itself.
Okay? It's like you're it's like you
live in three dimension, but you see two
two dimensions. And so you think only
two dimensions exist. And so they give
names to these two dimensional shapes.
They give it language. They create a
world around these things. Okay. This
becomes reality itself.
All right.
Okay.
Um so the thing to know about this is
that what wealth is
is consciousness. All
right.
And this is what hermetic philosophy
teaches us which is like everything is
just consciousness.
The imagination is the animating force
of the universe. Okay. Remember this
idea. The imagination or mind are what
gives life to the universe.
The second thing is that power is the
ability to direct consciousness.
All right. Which is just so the example
of course is money.
All right. So, money is not real. Money
is something that we just made up. But
we believe it's real.
And those who can make us believe money
is real are the ones who have the real
power. Okay. So, does it make sense? All
right. So, what I'm going to do now is
I'm going explain to you how Plato's
allegory of the cave explains the world
that we live in. Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> So there are two competing forces, two
competing power centers. They are
there'll be money and AI, artificial
intelligence.
Okay. Money and AI.
Okay.
All right. So let's let's look at money.
All right. The banks.
So in theory how this works is
depositors you guys you save enough
money and then you put your money in the
in the bank like a million dollars.
Okay. Then what the bank does is take
this million dollars and to create
wealth society gives it to entrepreneurs
loans it to entrepreneurs to do to to
create value in society. Okay.
Entrepreneurships.
[snorts]
And so in theory the bank should have
zero. Okay. Because what it's done is
it's taking your hard-earned money and
given to entrepreneurs to create more
value to give you jobs. Okay? And this
is what we believe how society works.
There's a problem with this. The problem
is that if you look at the bank balance
sheet, when it does this, when it takes
a million dollars and lends it out to $2
million, it doesn't have zero. It has $2
million.
So the great secret of our world is that
banks have the power to print as much
money as they want. So money if you
think about it is actually valueless.
Okay. But it's like lead but in our
world becomes go gold. So this is a
secret of alchemy.
How are banks able to trick you into
believing that lead is gold?
by using your imagination
by focusing your imagination in a world
that animates the world. Okay. So this
is about imagination
and this is the world that we live in.
All right. The thing that makes
um
money valuable and the only thing that
makes it valuable is the idea of
omnisient omnipresence.
It's everywhere. Okay. So, let's just
say I convince all you guys that your
dollar is worth nothing. And you're
like, "Yes, I agree." You go to America
and you you want to buy something.
You're like, and so the you you buy a
snack and the guy's like, "Okay, five
bucks." And you're like, "Yeah, but this
money is worthless." And he's like,
"Screw you, man. Where's my five bucks?"
Okay, do you understand? Doesn't matter
what you believe. It's the money is
valuable because it's everywhere and
everything. Okay? It is God.
So we create a society in which God
money is God because money is everywhere
and God is everywhere. Okay. All right.
So the problem with money though is that
if you can create out of thin air, you
must constantly destroy it as well. Does
it make sense to you guys? The banks can
create money out of thin air, then the
banks have to figure out ways to destroy
money as well. Otherwise, you have too
much money and no one's going to work,
right? The point of money is to get
people to work. And that means scarcity.
And so the way you do that is by
creating a
um
okay you there are two ways. Okay. The
first is uh financial collapse.
Okay. Basically basically a recession
or depression. The point of this is just
to remove money from the system. Okay.
It's wealth destruction because you
printed too much money. So you need you
need to destroy this money. Second way
of course is for wars.
And this helps us explain why things are
happening the way they are because these
past 10 20 years the Americans put in
too much money now and now they need to
create wars and to destroy this money so
that the global economy can continue.
Okay. The problem with this is that
it makes people question the authority
and the legitimacy of the elite. And
because of elite over over production,
this gives a possibility for a new elite
to arise. And this new elite is AI.
Okay? So um remember that money is
alchemy and that it's turning lead into
gold. Well, guess what guys? AI is also
alchemy and that is turning
um lead into gold. Okay, let me show you
how. Okay, so I'm going to put this in
very simple terms. But when you use AI,
what you're trying to do is you take out
you have a database.
You have lots of information in this
database and you trying to search and
sort
this database. Okay, there's information
in this database. You're trying to
organize this information in a way that
is useful and you're trying to search
information from this database that you
need at this moment. Okay? So, think of
like Google search, right? Google has
all the all the information in the
world. It's a database. Google organizes
it, sorts it, and then what you do is
you search for it for it. Okay? So,
Google is a database. All right? Um
the problem with the database is
eventually you reach a point where
there's just too much information and
you don't really know how to search and
sort it properly. So what you do is you
train the computer to do it for you.
Okay. How? So let's let's for example
use facial recognition
technology.
Let's just say you have like a billion
faces, one billion faces.
Now what you're trying to do is you're
trying to differentiate these bill faces
and you're trying to match it to the
proper name. Okay, you have a face
database. You have a name database and
you're trying to align the two together.
Okay, you don't know how to do it, but
so what you do is you train a computer
to do it for you. And so what you do is
you create a system of weights,
just a million variables. Okay,
variables.
And then the input, sorry.
Okay,
the input are just the databases, right?
And then the output is
uh yes or no. Does it match or doesn't
it match? Okay, depending on the output,
this information is fed back into the
database and the weights. Okay. And it
so what the computer is doing is it's
changing the weights in a certain way
that allows for all these bill faces to
match up with their names. All right.
And we call this back propagation
and that's how AI works and that's all
it does. Okay. Is it possible for us to
advance beyond this? The answer is no. I
don't care what you tell me. Okay. I've
done a lot of research in into the AI.
There's absolutely not nothing more we
can do than back propagation. What we do
what we do now is we now
give it names to make it sound very
fancy. Okay. So the weights is now
called neuronet network.
Okay. Um the back learning back
propagation is called deep learning
and this together is called AI. Okay.
That's it. Okay. What this is all
hallucination.
It's just clever marketing. That's all
it is. We [snorts] will never get beyond
this. Okay. And this is what allows for
uh large language models.
Okay. So you have a similar situation in
that money is just being printed out of
thin air and you have similation where
AI doesn't actually do anything. Okay.
So how you solve this problem is
twofold. The first thing you do is you
create omniscience.
Okay, what does this mean? It means the
way to solve the money problem is by
making money everywhere, right? Well,
the way to solve the AI problem is
making having AI know everything. That
means combining every single database in
the world into one major database. Does
it make sense?
Okay, that's the idea where you're born,
the hospital, your health records, it's
all in one database. You go to school,
how well you do in school, what what
your teacher say about you, it's all in
the same database. When you grow up,
what job you do, what you buy, it's all
in one database. Your police record, one
database. Your health records, one
database.
Okay? Your browsing uh history, one
database. And then I have omniscience on
you. Okay? Then it gives the illusion of
AI of God because he knows everything
everything about you. Okay.
And then the second thing it does is
it um
becomes a religion.
Okay. For AI to be fully AI, it needs to
turn itself into a religion where
everyone is worshiping it. And the way
you do that is by making people believe
that this thing is alive because demons
have been summoned into it because Jesus
is resurrecting itself through AI. You
understand? Okay. You want to trick
people to believe that behind all this
electricity behind all this um
semiconductors
it's an interdimensional portal for
demons for Jesus to come alive in. Once
people believe that then the imagination
takes effect and the imagination will
then animate the AI. Okay, that's the
trick. Once they achieve these two
things omniscience and religion, then AI
will be achieved in this world. Okay. So
what's happening today is
a civil war. Okay. In the world where
right now money which is controlled by
transnational capital
is god.
They're trying to train a new they're
trying to create a new god called AI.
Okay. An AI god. Okay. So there are
three po three forces of polish
transational capital. They are
nationalism,
religion
and AI. Okay. And altogether they're
trying to create a AI god in order to
replace money.
Okay. So um I was talking to my wife
about this idea and one question she has
for me is what's the conflict here?
What's the problem? Why is why is there
war? Why can't transational capital be
just become
the AI god? And the answer is because
these are two fundamentally different
systems. Okay, think like this. I'm
going to put this in very simple terms,
but think of transactional capital as
capitalism. Okay, free market capitalism
and what is
AI god? It's technomarxism.
Okay,
the difference is this. The difference
is that with money,
everyone still has a lot of freedom,
okay, to generate as much money as
possible, but there's still freedom in
place. Whereas with a technoarxist
system, you have an elite who control
the god AI god who then control
all your attention.
Okay? It's basically technos slavery.
So imagine a computer chip implanted
into your brain that tells you
everything. Okay? You don't have to
think anymore. You just have to listen
to this microchip. Tells you, "Hey, you
show up at 7 o'clock in the morning.
When you get up 7 o'clock in the
morning, go run uh for half an hour."
And you fall in love with the system
because you don't have to think anymore.
There's this microchip who you think is
actually the voice of God. It's an
angel. It's a demon. But it's all coming
from God. Okay? And this microchip is
this AI system is helping you live the
best possible life. You're now more
healthy. You're now more hardworking.
You're more successful. You find
happiness in your life. Okay. So this is
uh where the world is going. And
underneath everything that that we've
seen so far, the geopolitics, this is
actually the real conflict in the world,
the real transition of the world where
one god money is being replaced by
another god, the AI god. Okay. All
right. So um what I've done what I've
done is basically giving you a complete
understanding of how the world works a
framework a predictive history framework
for understanding how the world works
which then allows us to make predictions
about the world. Okay depending on our
predictions the predictions we can then
go back and refine this model. All
right. So basically this the the entire
point of this class is help us observe
the world better to learn about the
world better. Okay. So again it's all
speculation. I'm not saying this is 100%
correct. All right. Most of this might
may even be wrong but at least it gives
us a framework for us to learn about
ourselves and the world around us. All
right. Okay. Any questions?
question about money which is that USA
have like around 39 trillion national
debt but if the banks really have the
power to print m as money as more money
as they want why don't they just print
so money and like hide them and solve
this that
>> okay um yeah okay again I mean
all right I'll explain it to you all
Right. All right. All right. How does
the debt work? The debt is very simple.
I'm the US government. Okay.
I don't print money, but I need to spend
money. So, I borrow money, right? So, I
have I borrow money from something
called the Federal Reserve,
which is able to print money. Okay? Do
you understand so far?
>> All right. But for the Federal Reserve
to lend you money, they want to profit
from it. So they charge you an interest,
right? 5%. Is usually the interest. So
right now the the US government debt is
$39 trillion in debt.
Right now interest rate means the US
government has to pay $2 trillion a year
in interest payments alone. And you're
like, well, why doesn't US government
just not pay the interest rate interest
because it's a government. It can do
what it wants. No, that's not how the
system works because the Federal Reserve
borrows its money from banks which then
borrows it money from depositors.
Okay? Does that make sense? From you
basically. So you're the one and you
don't even know you're the one doing it,
but you're the one lending money to the
US government. So the government has to
pay you back interest.
Okay? So if the US government would say,
"Screw this. I'm not paying off this
debt." Then this entire system collapses
and then people recognize that it was
all just a hallucination. Money is not
God. Money is not valuable. Money is
worthless. It's just lead. I thought it
was gold all this time and now it's just
lead. So what do you do? You revolt. You
burn things down. You're angry now.
Okay. So US government cannot afford to
not pay off this debt. So despite that
the Federal Reserve might can print as
much money that they want but they still
cannot solve this problem right because
if they so if the US government really
choose not to pay the interest the whole
system just collapse.
>> Okay. Okay. So you need you need to
prioritize ideas. This is just the
surface. This is what we just look at.
Underneath all this is Plato's cave.
What Phil's cave teaches us is that as
long as we believe that money is real,
then it's real. So this entire system is
set up to trick us into believing money
is real. Okay? As long as we believe
money is real, this doesn't matter. The
the US government could have like $500
trillion in debt. Who cares? As long as
you're willing to still use money, as
long as you're still willing to believe
in money as God, this doesn't matter.
The problem is that from a fiscal
perspective, you have too much debt,
it's harder and harder for you to run
the government. Okay? If you it's harder
and harder for you to run the government
and people are no longer getting basic
services like health care and water,
then they question the very foundations
of society, which leads them to question
the very foundations of money itself.
Okay. So, this is a huge problem. But
you first have to understand that it's
the human imagination that is the key. I
need to trick you into believing
something. Okay. As as long as I'm able
to make you still believe in this thing,
I'm okay.
All right.
Okay.
>> Yeah. Alan.
So I have a questions about money as
well. As you say like money is an
hallucinations that prevent us from
seeing the other like truths. But what
is the motivations for those uh guys who
create the motivations? Is that for
power? But isn't power a motivate a
hallucination as well? Like
>> Okay. All right. Back. Okay. So, this
this is hard for you guys. Okay. I It's
really hard. All right. Okay. Plato's
cave.
All right.
The imagination,
the consciousness
is the energy of the world. You
understand? It's it's the only thing
that exists in this world. So what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to suck your
energy for myself.
You understand? Because the only energy
is real. Everything else is is is is
false. Everything comes from energy.
Everything comes from imagination. Okay.
So how do I get your energy and then
transfer to me? By tricking you into
believing that by using your energy,
you're using it for yourself. And the
mechanism I do that is through money.
Okay.
All right. So the example is let's just
say I
um ask you to build me a house. Okay.
I'm going to live in the house.
And you're like, "Well, I'm not you're
someone else is going to live in the
house. I'm not going to live in the
house. So I I don't really care." Okay.
So you don't really do a serious job.
You spend five days building me a house.
It's a crappy house.
So what I do now is I say, "Hey, Alan,
let me give you a million dollars to
build me a house. Now you take it much
more seriously." Right? Now you spend a
lot of time. You spent two years
building me a great house for me to live
in. So what I did, what I've done is
I've taken your energy, your attention,
and basically
use it for my own ends. Does it make
sense?
>> Okay. And the only reason why you do
that is you think that this million
dollars is actually worth more than my
own energy, right? Because these two
years I could go read books. I could
write poetry. I could go fishing. Why am
I going to build this stupid house for
like for for this other guy? Cuz he gave
me money, a million dollars.
Okay, does that make sense?
Right. So what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to capture everyone's energy for
myself.
And the mechanism I do that is through
money. If I can't use money, then I need
to use something else. Imag that has to
be AI.
Okay.
What but what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to capture your energy, your
imagination, your consciousness, your
attention because that's the only value
in this world.
All right.
Make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. All right. So I present this
theory and you guys what I want you guys
to do for homework is think of this
theory and come up with ideas arguments
against this theory or show me where
this theory is wrong. Okay? And people
online can participate as well. So on
Thursday we will do the final
examination. Okay? I'm going to answer
your questions and we're going to look
at and I I will answer your questions
using this theoretical framework.
All right? so we can expand on it,
better understand it. And what's really
important is for everyone to constantly
question and be skeptical about my ideas
because I'm also trying to figure out
how the world works. And this is a
theory that I have so far. Okay. All
right. So, I'll see everyone on
Thursday.